for a long time i I used to say about
the Semantic Web that it sounded neat
but I don't understand it and take a
little deeper than that what I found is
every time I would start trying to learn
something about the Semantic Web I would
end up reading these sort of very long
dry abstract theoretical policy
documents that I felt were unrealistic
and and didn't tell me what I'm supposed
to do I always like to say I'm a
carpenter not an architect right and so
sort of grand theory of architecture
sounds great and all but I'm a carpenter
I don't know what to do with it I
actually need the architects to give me
something give me a plan so I can start
hammering and nailing and actually
building the thing and we're actually
getting closer to that now and I think a
lot of the ideas around the Semantic Web
are are beginning to come to fruition
you know we have people lots of people
doing things like tagging photos at
Flickr or adding articles to categories
at Wikipedia those are the kinds of
things that you know people are
beginning to generate data metadata
that's machine readable and usable by
computers to help us find and navigate
and do all that kind of cool stuff so
for me I think that's that's the first
steps in that direction and that's
hardly that the dream of the Semantic
Web but at the same time I'm a little
skeptical of a lot of things in this
area I know there are a lot of people
who are working on natural language
processing and semantic search and I
four right now I haven't seen anything
particularly useful about that and I've
actually talked to people I'm speaking
now just for the moment from the
perspective of search engines I've
talked to some people at Google who
share that sentiment I don't know if
everybody in Google does for all I know
they're working on a top-secret natural
language processing program but to say
you know keyword based searching where
the machine doesn't even attempt to
understand what the document is about
actually works pretty well and it you
know having the ability for a machine to
read a document and understand it in
some vague sense doesn't seem to be
particularly helpful for most of the
real problems that we face in search so
at least for right now given that the
technology is very limited in scope I
just don't see
you